what I want to do in this video is a
little bit of 1960s US economic history
and then just see if our aggregate
demand aggregate supply model fits the
description of what actually happened
and one could argue you don't need the a
das model to to to describe what
happened but we should at least make
sure that it does describe what happened
so if we go to 1960
so 1960 this is the very end of the
Eisenhower administration Eisenhower was
a Republican in office and I the only
reason why I give his pot his party
affiliation is because if the economy is
weak and in 1960 the economy was weak
and one can always debate whether it was
due to the government or whether the
weather was due to just the natural
fluctuations in the economy but in
general when the economy is weak it
tends to go against the party that is in
power and so in 1960 the Republicans
were in power there was a recession and
one could argue that was a major reason
why the Democratic candidate in the 1960
election was able to win John F Kennedy
and so in 1961 JFK is inaugurated he
becomes President of the United States
and one of his top goals is to try to
turn around this economy and he does it
with what can best be described as
Keynes Ian's policies and we'll talk
more about that in future videos in fact
I should probably devote many videos to
Keynes Ian's policies but it's a general
idea that the government might be able
to turn around or recession by sparking
demand and the way that it would spark
demand is try to put more money in
people's pockets or even in business's
pockets and it would do that through
some combination of increased government
spending maybe somehow giving money to
the poor some types of transfer programs
and tax cuts for people and for
businesses so that they have more money
to spend and so these policies get
implemented and over john f kennedy's
term you do have GDP GDP begins to turn
back around unemployment unemployment so
I'll just write employment goes up
employment goes up and inflation stays
low inflation inflation is low so these
are all of the things that you want in
and economy and unfortunate
unfortunately and this is just kind of a
sad human event in 1963 1963 John F
Kennedy you probably know is
assassinated and then his Vice President
Lyndon Baines Johnson that is LBJ right
over there
Lyndon Baines Johnson becomes president
lb J becomes president a little bit of
trivia he's tied for the tallest
president in US history tied with
Abraham Lincoln at six foot four and so
he inherits a very very good economy
almost one could argue a perfect economy
and in if if Keynes Ian policies were
really to be practiced here to their
full to their full idea in theory once
the economy started to get a little bit
really overheated and really approaching
its potential and maybe 1964-1965 the
government maybe should have started to
pull back a little bit on its spending
so that the economy doesn't get
overheated but Lyndon Baines Johnson did
not do this he kept things going in fact
he added more fuel to the fire and one
could argue some of it was driven by
geopolitics a major factor was right
over here the Vietnam War which was
escalated in a major way under LBJ's
administration JFK was already dabbling
in Vietnam but it became a really a
major war for the United States under
Lyndon Baines Johnson so some
combination of Vietnam and he had a
Vietnam and he had a huge number of
social programs increased government
spending to try to ease inequality in
the US as well so social program so one
could call guns and butter social social
programs to try to ease inequality but
the the the net effect of this is
government spending even though the
economy was already red-hot it was
already at its potential it was he
wanted to increase government spending
even more and so he kind of took it
beyond its potential he made it overheat
a little bit and what happens in 1966
and onwards 1966 and onwards is that you
have inflation starting to grow at a
fairly uncomfortable rate inflation
starts to grow dramatically and just to
get a sense of it when I keep saying
that the the economy was at its
potential and maybe he might have taken
a little
his pedal off the gas or his foot off of
the pedal I should say is in as we get
into the beginning of his administration
1964-1965
unemployment is in the four five percent
range inflation is in the one two
percent range GDP is growing at a very
at a very healthy rate but despite that
and maybe he was you know he could argue
maybe his hand was forced by
geopolitical events especially on
military funding the government
continues to even spend more money
stimulates things even more because that
money goes to soldier salaries it goes
to companies that provide I guess that
make napalm or make boats or make
whatever else and so you get more even
and all of these government programs
inject even more dollars into the
economy and so you ended up with
inflation the economy was already
operating at close to capacity and it
made it go even maybe even beyond its
natural capacity and let's see whether
our a das model this would make would
allow for this to happen or would
describe this or would predict this
given what was going on so let's draw so
that right over there is my price axis
and this right over here is my real GDP
axis we scroll down a little bit this
right over here is real GDP and so if we
go into the 1964 1965 time frame you
could say that u.s. is performing at its
potential GDP its potential GDP and when
I talk about its potential GDP I'm
saying that on the long-run assuming
that people aren't overworked assuming
that factories they're getting their
proper maintenance they're not being
kind of run so hard that they start you
know kind of cracking at the seams this
is how much that the US can produce in
theory if everyone worked even harder
and didn't sleep and it kind of do we're
doing things in an unsustainable way
they might even be able to they might
even be able to produce more one could
view this as a theoretical maximum but
when we talk about potential we're not
talking about that short-term
theoretical maximum we're talking about
the kind of the the maximum GDP that a
that a economy can produce I guess you
could say in a healthy way or taking it
or over the long-run assuming that
people aren't overworked and that the
factories aren't overworked
in some way shape or form so this could
be our situation maybe in 1964-1965
let's draw maybe this right over here is
the level of prices but we just want to
see if in general we get this type of
thing happening from our model so this
is our aggregate supply in the long run
our aggregate supply in the short run we
know might look something like aggregate
supply and the short run might look
something like this
so that's aggregate supply in the short
run and then from our model we will
assume let me actually let me draw it a
little bit neater
so it intersects a little bit better so
this right over here is aggregate let me
draw it a little bit better than that
what the slope so this is our aggregate
supply in the short-run so aggregate
supply in the short run and let's draw
our aggregate demand aggregate demand
I'll do that in this green color so
aggregate demand might look something
like that
so that is our aggregate demand so this
is 1964-1965 here we are the economy's
humming along at its potential now more
gas is thrown on the flame government
accelerates its spending not just to
turn on the economy now because of
Vietnam and all of these social programs
so what's going to happen well that
money is ending up in company and
people's pockets they are going to
demand more it's going to shift the
demand curve to the right at any given
price they're going to demand more so
aggregate demand is going to shift to
the right and maybe it goes it shifts to
the right and maybe it goes someplace
right over there so what is the new
short-term equilibrium well aggregate
demand is intersecting aggregate supply
right over here right over there and as
we see the equilibrium level of prices
on this model now has gone up our
productivity we're now producing above
potential we're overheating a little bit
something on and actually if you look at
the data in 1966 1967 unemployment did
become ridiculously low it even had a
gotten kind of the three point something
percent for a little while so really and
that some people and many people would
argue that even
that is an unnaturally level low level
of unemployment that people and and
factories are really operating at maybe
beyond full capacity or beyond a
sustainable full capacity but we see
from this model what you think would
happen actually does happen prices would
go up and hat right over there and then
on the long run you really wouldn't be
able to sustain this level of producing
above your potential and over the long
run things would settle back right over
here and all you're left with really is
the inflation